pensemos que tenemos dos rectas
paralelas esta de acá y esta de acá y
que son atravesadas por una misma
transversal déjame primero marcar que
son paralelas esta es paralela a esta de
acá y son atravesadas por una misma
transversal que voy a poner de color
azul algo así vale e imagina que también
sabemos que la medida de este ángulo de
aquí de este ángulo de aquí adentro
déjame tomar la otra herramienta es
igual a 9 x + 88 a 9 x + 88 y que la
medida de este ángulo de acá este de acá
es igual a 6 x + 182 es igual a 6 x +
182 y que a partir de aquí queremos
determinar cuál es la medida de cada uno
de estos dos ángulos bueno te invito a
detener el vídeo para que lo pienses por
tu cuenta
porque ahorita ya vamos a empezar a ver
la solución vale
resulta que la clave para determinar la
medida de estos dos ángulos está en
darse cuenta que están relacionados a
través de esta transversal que corta a
las dos paralelas por ejemplo este
ángulo que es de 6 x 182 es
correspondiente con este de acá este de
acá también mide 6 x más 182 todos los
ángulos están en grados vale pero bueno
si este 6 x 182 eso nos permite darnos
cuenta que los dos ángulos el rojo y el
verde son suplementarios porque forman
esta recta a la recta azul y de esta
forma tenemos que su suma debe ser igual
a 180 grados es decir 6x más 182 más 9 x
88 más 9 x más 88 es igual a 180 grados
a 180 grados y esto nos da una ecuación
con la cual podemos trabajar 6 x + 9 x
es igual a 15
15 x 182 más 88 es igual a 270 182 más
88 si haber 8 con 182 190 más 80 son 270
ajá 270 y eso de ahí debe ser igual a
180 grados 180 grados podemos restar 270
de ambos lados restamos 270 restamos 270
y entonces nos queda que 15 x 15 x
es igual a 180 menos 270 es decir es
igual a menos 90 grados y con eso
tenemos que x es igual a menos 90 grados
en los 90 dividido entre 15 que es igual
a menos 6 entonces x el valor de x es
menos 6 sale pero eso nos da únicamente
el valor de xx igual a menos 6 sin
embargo lo que nosotros queríamos
determinar era el valor del ángulo rojo
y el ángulo verde así que ahora debemos
sustituir este valor acá para ver qué
nos queda aquí sería 9 x menos 6 es
menos 54 déjalo apuntó es 9 x menos 6 es
menos 54 ya eso tenemos que sumarle 88
88 menos 54 es igual a 34
34 entonces el ángulo rojo mide 34
grados vale y el ángulo verde pues bueno
ya sabemos que es suplementario con el
rojo entonces debe ser lo que falta para
180 es decir 146 pero también podemos
verificarlo sustituyendo x igual a menos
6 aquí lo que nos quedaría sería menos 6
x menos 6 o sea menos 36 más 182 si le
restó 6 me queda 176 si restó otros 30
me queda ciento 146 bajar 146 esto de
aquí es igual a 146 y en efecto podemos
verificar que la suma de los 12 180 146
más 30 de 176 y 4 son 180 entonces en
efecto son ángulos suplementarios y con
esto podemos determinar el valor de
todos los ángulos de la figura si este
de acá fue de 146 eso puesto por el
vértice con este de acá que también mide
146 que es correspondiente con este de
acá
con este de acá entonces también mide
ya vimos que éste era correspondiente
con este así que éste también es de 146
grados y el rojo el rojo mide 34 grados
que hace que este también sea 34 grados
propuestos por el vértice que hace que
éste sea 34 grados 34 grados porque son
correspondientes y que hace que éste sea
34 grados